there are three ways and you might
remember what the three ways are we're
going to do them all on the board there
are three ways you can change a shape so
that transformers shape so that it still
has the same size it still has the same
shape okay
I wonder you remember what the three are
who wants to give me a hand up to give
me the first transformation some of it
Melanie give me the first one rotation
all right let's go number one now if you
have these in a different order that's
totally okay we're going to do all three
in whichever order K now before heads
out for second before we go into the
other ones rotation is out technical
name for this what's a simpler name I
said okay you can do turn right or if
you like there's another one if I would
probably say spin either of these would
be acceptable as talking about exactly
the same thing so let's all draw if
you'd like you can draw a different
letter but I think Ozzy Kuiper's I could
rotate turn spin around how am I going
to do it
there we go
so draw me a shape now you can see
rotation right it needs a place where am
i rotating around okay so you can see on
my pair of ours right there is one point
that hasn't moved anywhere right so for
instance see this point it's moved all
the way over here see this point it's
moved all the way over here where's the
point that hasn't moved
yeah me know how would we describe it we
describe it there's a corner which
corner is it is a couple of coins bottom
left corner it's like yeah you see that
that's my op that's my point of rotation
okay I could have retained it elsewhere
I could have rotated around T out
already got a different shape the point
is done same size same shape I could
move it back and it's to be fine okay
number one with rotations number two
someone give me another one okay oh by
sliding okay so this slide is one of our
informal work what's our technical name
for sliding yeah today translation very
good okay so joy yourself ain't neva are
for matter of choice so for instance
this R here if I simply move it to the
right like so just moved it over in fact
let's add some extra fees here right I'm
going to indicate my translation with an
arrow
it's a straight arrow but go straight
parent for translation
what could error would I have over here
yeah but it's going around like this
right so you can see that location okay
last one I think we'll be able to fit it
just over here
number three hands up couldn't say
they've done it flip okay
flip is one of our nice simple words
what's out technique wait for it right
in reflection excellent so this is what
we're doing in a mirror
okay so Mira is also another word we use
it's less fine it's okay that's what
mirrors do sorry let's put our lost now
if I put that let it man okay I'm going
to reflect it flip it mirror it
downwards okay so I'm going to get a
shape out this space
alright now here's an interesting thing
right
Cielo will be rotated we've rotated
around a point the retainer at a point
but when you reflect you don't reflect
around a point
you don't even reflect across a point
you're reflecting across a wide right in
fact you can see the light I'm
reflecting is right so this is the one
and I reflect across it if you like this
would be kind like where the mirror is
okay we're going to indicate that just
like we did with these others with a
lion okay but I'm gonna drive Johnson of
mine across like that often also called
an axis of reflection rotation
translation reflection you're going to
see a series of shapes and you're going
to be changing them identifying which
kind of transformation is used now one
last thing before we are leave off of
this do you notice that some of these
transformations can be combined in
different ways to give the others
example I know I need to do this I'll
see if I can I want you to imagine this
reflection so you have just ripped like
that what if I reflected it a game a
similar way downwards again so if I
reflected it here can you see how you
reflect once and then I do reflect twice
do you see it but if I can see to my
first and loss chase what kind of
transformation is that it's not a
reflection at all is it it's a it's a
translation right you see it's just if I
take away this middle guy all that left
with is a translation it's just slid
downwards
so I can combine two reflections in
order to get a translation I can go a
little further than that
for instance I'm gonna do another
reflection but this time I'm going to go
in a different direction okay
for instance and fire off like this guy
and reflective instead of downwards if I
reflect him to the left
have a look at that okay now I reflect
what's down with manners like the second
time to the left again I'm going to take
out the middle man what kind of
transformation is that yeah that said
that's actually just a little so you can
see that's just our rotation isn't it
in fact it's this rotation if I kept
going a bit further right I rotated 90
degrees here if I returned another 90
degrees
I didn't hear okay sir reflection is
kind of cool depending on which way you
reflect you'll get maybe a translation
or maybe a rotation right so you can
combine them in different ways